My name is Bill Durham. I'm Bing Professor in
Human Biology, in human biology and anthropology at Stanford University.
>> Well, we're really happy you're joining us, especially to talk about a
very important concept. Now, we've just
been learning about lactose intolerance, and about
the idea that as all infants, we had the ability as mammals to
digest these lactose containing products. And as
we get older, our lactase expression diminishes.
But in some people, the lactase gene sort of stays
on, and we continue to make lactase. And so I guess
we'll start out by asking, why, in human evolution, would
something like this happen? How could something like this even happen?
>> Well from a pan-mammalian background, where the
lactase activity peaks around birth and then tails
off quickly into the weaning period and into
adulthood, we assume, we know that that's pan-mammalian.
Even your house cat is lactose malabsorbed, a malabsorber
or lactose intolerant. At least every house cat that's
been tested is, even though people will give milk
to their house cats. And we don't know is
whether the people have found the threshold, or the
cat's found the threshold, to avoid diearaha and other
consequences. What's interesting, then, is from that background of
a peak, some human populations show persistant lactase activity into
adulthood, while the majority continue to decline.
So it's that, minority of lactose-tolerant adults
that are really fascinating. it's a wonderful
question. Because here's a case where you have
an intraspecific polymorphism. You have the existence
in, if the ongoing persistence of a genetic
difference between human populations, with regard to
some relatively simple trait. And a trait that
has to be relatively recent in human history.
>> Sure.
>> There were no sources of milk prior to dairy animals.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> So, what we have here is, I mean,
of the mother's milk, there were no mammalian sources of
milk for human populations before agriculture. So, we assume
that the panamalian background, means that at the dawn of
history, human populations were all lactose intolerant. And that
there would be at best, a mutationly low frequency of
individuals that varied on that characteristic. And because it was
a very low variation and there was no milk available,
we would have no way of knowing how much
there was or how often it recurred and so on.
But what we have then, in the meantime, is
this great invention called agriculture. The domestication of plants and
animals at the service of the human food supply.
We have every reason to believe that, the main animals
that are used for milk today were originally domesticated for
meat. They were valued first for meat, and that milk
was, as the expression goes, was part of
a secondary products revolution where they realize you
could use more then the meat from these
animals. Goat, sheep, you know, cattle and so on.
And so they already probably had them in
close association with human communities. They were probably already
harvesting the meat regularly. They probably had mastered,
over winter, water supply, hearding activities, and that sort
of thing. And then suddenly there's evidence for using the,
the milk product of these animals. some of the earliest evidence comes from
Sahara rock paintings that are dated to 4,500 B.P., that show,
in fact, bringing the calf up near the
female, the adult female, and a human being underneath.
Now we infer that the human being underneath
is doing this. What else is a human being
doing under a cow?
[LAUGH]
and the question really is what was the added value of drinking fresh milk?
It's complicated on the one hand, because
you had the meat value of these animals
you domesticated. So, it seems unlikely that
it would be just the protein or food
supply. Yet, that was important to our
argument. The question, and it's also complicated because,
there are ways to get some food value from milk without drinking it fresh. You
can all societies that I know of, have ways of processing fresh milk into low
lactose forms. Sour milk is a low lactose form. All the things like yogurt and
kefir, drinks that are widely known in some
places, and most cheeses, break down the lactose
externally using lactobacillus bacteria, using a separation of curds and whey.
Lactose is water soluble, it drains off with the whey, and the
curds are free of lactose. So most cheeses have very little
lactose concentration, something like yogurt is
full of lactobacillus, that's already digesting.
>> Sure.
>> The lactose for human consumption. So here's the real challenge. In a world
where most populations have ways to process milk
and to get everything that's in the milk.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Why would some populations still evolve this persistent lactase activity?
>> Sure.
>> Because there are external sources of
lactase, why does it have, what, what was
the advantage of producing it internally to the
human organism? The leading argument of the day
is that calcium, that the advantage of drinking fresh milk, is the
advantage of an additional calcium supply especially in areas where there is,
a calcium deficiency caused either by inadequate calcium in the
diet. Well, that's not too likely if you're drinking milk.
>> Sure.
>> but a vitamin D scarcity. And then
people say, well, what's the advantage? Milk is obviously
rich in calcium but what's the advantage of having
why, why can't you again just eat the yogurt?
>> Mm-hm.
>> And why can't you again just eat the milk product, the cheese,
which is going to have the calcium in it? Except for the water soluble calcium
which you might lose some of. What's
interesting with some research what's called the lactose
effect. If you feed human infants from birth,
in a compare, a controlled comparison, cow's milk
>> Mm-hm.
>> from birth, or mother's milk, versus soy milk, you see, beginning in a
matter of, of a few days, you see a big differential in the amount of
bone absorbed calcium, in other words, the calcification of bone
>> Mm-hm.
>> Is enhanced, you can, this is
controlling for the amount of calcium, you take
soymilk, and you supplement the calcium in it, so that it matches the cows milk.
They have the same calcium, and the
presence of the lactose enhances the absorption of
the calcium according to this, these data. it's
a magnificent curve and it, what it shows
is that the ability to drink fresh milk
has the advantage of making the calcium that's
there in equal proportion in the two milks.
It makes it more available to the infants
who can absorb, who can digest the lactose.
So what's particularly interesting about that is it's
saying that a lactase persistence compensates for the
vitamin D deficiency that's built into the solar
radiation pattern on the surface of our Earth. So
that milk, like epidermal demelanization, they follow similar curves.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that you get the persistent lactase
activity. And the lactose tolerance at high latitudes.
>> Right. And just to sort of reword what you say here to make
sure you know we're clear on this, in the case for skin pigmentation,
as you've sort of alluded to, the idea
is as human migration moved away from the equator
>> Yeah.
>> to higher and I guess we should also say lower latitudes
>> Yes.
>> They had less sunlight and so they
>> Well, you can say higher latitudes north and south.
>> Sure higher latitudes north and south. They lost pigmentation in the
skin, because they needed to let more sunlight in for vitamin D.
>> There was selection for the entrance of more sunlight.
It wasn't that they recognized the need.
>> Sure. Good, yes. Exactly
>> The same with milk, it wasn't that
we were sitting around here, wow, hoping and wishing
we could have another source of calcium. What's
happening is that those that happened to have this
>> Mm hm.
>> Out-reproduced by, you can even test whether it's a 3%, a 2%, a 5%. How
much does the difference have to be in
the long run, in terms of differential survival and
reproduction, in order for this to work out in
the time frame that we have from 4,500 years B.P.,
or whatever. And I'm one of those who thinks
that it's actually a pretty small advantage. A pretty small
advantage, but persistent generation after generation, and no fail,
it's there. If you have the lactose mechanism for absorbing
calcium and making strong bones, less likely to have
rickets, less likely to have Harrison Sulcus, less likely to
have broken bones in young adulthood and
all those things. You'll have that rigid calcification
of bone, which you can see starting
right out in infancy with the lactose affect.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Of course,
thank you.